ありがとうございました
えっと 質問なんですけれども
あの五蓋の五蓋についてですね
ちょっとよくわからないんですけれども
あの 五蓋をなくすには智慧が必要だということですよね
逆 五蓋がなくしたことが智慧なんです
え で 智慧があれば五蓋はなくなるんですか？ 逆です
はい あ えーそうしますとですね
あの ちょっと理解できないんですけども
具体的にその五蓋をなくす方法というのはどういうことをやったらいいんでしょう
ただ 五蓋を発見していればね
例えば異常な欲が出たら
これはまずいって思えばなくなるでしょ
これは論理的じゃない
常識じゃないと この欲は常識じゃない
それはさようならというだけでなくなりますよ
怒ってきたと これは理由がなく怒ったんだから
これはダメですよと そういう風に
その場でそれを覚えておく必要で
まず覚えておく それからいつでも自分の心にチェックを入れてみる
あるかないか あるかないかだ
あると見つけたらすぐなくす
その場でなくせます それで五蓋がなくなっていくんですよ
なくなっていくと智慧が自動的に現れる
あの真鍮で作ってる品物あるでしょ？置物とか
放っておけば暗くなるでしょ
錆びるんだからね だから錆を取れば輝くんでしょ
逆はないんです この真鍮の置物が輝いて輝いているならば
錆がないんだと 話にならない
錆がなくすために輝いていなくちゃいけないんだ
そんなこと考えなくてもいいんだ
錆って錆だから 真鍮磨きで磨けばいいんです
錆が落ちるんです 錆が落ちたらもうピカピカ輝いているんです
だから我々は五蓋を落とすんです
はい あの 今 真鍮の例で真鍮ってサビを落とす方法がわからないんです
今それが言ったんです
だからすごい え？ その都度その都度
五蓋について気がついたら
その うーん 気がつく 気をつける
五蓋に気をつけなさいよという先生のお話はわかるんですけれども
えっとまあ 私は特にどうしたって渾沈睡眠系の人間なもんでして
あの それ気がついてるんですけれども
そのどうどうやって気がついてるのに
その渾沈睡眠をどうやってその気がついてる渾沈睡眠をなくしたらいいのかっていう
その  だからそこはそんなにまず大げさに考えてるみたいですね
その大げさに考えるのはすごい具体的に
例えば渾沈睡眠系になっちゃったら
ちょっと外出て走ったっていいでしょうに
ちょっとジョギングしたっていいでしょうに
なくなるでしょ あるいは水風呂に入っちゃうとかね
それくらい単純なんです
で できるだけ立っているとかね
立っているとかね そういうすごいシンプルな方法で
その都度なくすんです
それがすごい特効薬の専業なんですよ
だから専業の結果でどんどんどんどんうまくいくんです
決して大げさに見てはいけないんです
とっても簡単にそこはなんとかできます
だから渾沈睡眠系になっちゃうと
まあ家で座って ソファにそこから立ちたくないでしょうに
他に何か方法はあるのかと
それはないんです それでソファに座るんじゃなくて
立ちなさいよ 散歩でもちょっと歩くことでもしなさいよ
で そういう風にもう あるいはもう冷たい水でシャワーでもやっちゃうとかね
それが活発になる それで渾沈睡眠が消えちゃう
で 義もとにかくブッダの教えはもう絶対的に信じてやるぞっていうぐらいで
それもなくなる そんなに大げさなことじゃないんです
はい 大げさと思ったらダメなんです
大変だと思ったらダメなんです
すごいシンプルになくなりました
ありがとうございました
はいはい  ありがとうございました
今の五蓋のまた質問なんですけれども
この4番目のですね 情と後悔というのが一緒になってるんですけれども
この 2つには何か関連性っていうか
あの 同じような意味があるんでしょうか
そこはそうっとそう一緒になってるんだから
私もなんで一緒にしてるのかっていうことはもうわからないんで
正直なところは 後悔は怒りなんですね
結局は ウッダッチは無知なんですね
だから無知と怒りはワンセットにしているんです
義も無知の心なんですね
それは一つ自由にさせてるんですね
おそらく一冊にまとめたかったんじゃないかなと思います
[笑い]六つにしても構いませんしね
で 懇親睡眠はワンセットにしたのは
それは理由わかります
だから 情鼓っていうのはなんか興奮状態で落ち着かない状態
集中できない状態 情後悔っていうのは過去のことを後悔するんだから
当然落ち着きではないんですね
そういうところでまとめたでしょう
後悔する人は過去のことで後悔するばっかりで仕事はしない
それで仕事をしようと思っても落ち着かないんですね
後悔のせいで そこでなんとか関連性あるみたい
あの 未来のことに焦ることと
過去のことに引っかかることっていう解釈で
ん？ 情は焦る 未来のことを焦っていて
後悔は過去に引っかかっているっていうような解釈では
もう強引にそういう風に言うのはまあ別にいいかもしれませんけど
やっぱり伝統的に仏教の解説方法ではそう使ってないんだからね
まあその風な解説もはめるかもしれません
後悔といえば過去のことだから
だったら上戸っていうのは将来のことではないかと
それもそうかもしれませんよ
だって焦ってるのは結果見るんだから焦ってるんだからね
おそらくそれそうかもしれません
だから我々の解説のまあ 1本の道が流れがあるんだからね
まあその中にはないんですけどね
まあその方法ももしかするといいとは思いますよ
はい 他のご質問ございますか？はい
先ほどの方の五蓋をあという方法で
あのやり方の方法論なんですけど
あの怒りですね それが割と私の場合はですね
怒りというか なんかこう
世の中ちょっとしたことでもなんかおかしいんじゃないかと思ってしまって
それが結局だんだんムラムラとしてくる傾向があるんですね
例えば 電車に乗ってても
学生風の男が席をビトッと自分で占領してですね
カバンを置いて足を前に投げ出して座ってるのを見てると
周りとは割と平気な顔して仕方がないわねのように顔してるんですけど
私なんか見てるとそんな席を占領しておかしいなと
だんだん腹が立ってきて注意したくなってきて
以前はよくそういうのを注意してたんですけど
最近長老の本を読んで
あまりそういうことを聞いて怒らない方がいいんじゃないかと思って無視するようにしてるんですけど
昨日もちょっとあの社会保険庁の方に年金の相談で来て
相談の人はですね 私がその本人
本人確認証を持ってこなかったんで
本来は相談に乗ってあげない
られないんだけど 今日は特別に正常な資料を持ってきたので見てあげますよな態度ですね
ちょっと女性の相談員だったんですけどね
されたんで その辺がだんだん腹が立ってきましてですね
で 私が質問以外のことをですね
先輩はベラベラベラベラと喋ってですね
こちらの質問をなかなか聞いてもらえないんで
だんだん腹が立ってきたんで
やっぱり長老の教えがあったんで
我慢しよう 我慢しようと思ってたんですけど
我慢できなくなって この人を他の人と変えてくれということでですね
他の人のちょっと怒って
他の人に変えて変えてもらったことが昨日ちょっとあったんですけど
だからそういうふうに
やっぱり日常生活に入ると
なんかすぐちょっとおかしいんじゃないかというのが頭をもたげてきて
怒りがだんだん湧いてくるので
結果的には爆発してしまうことが多いんですね
はい その場合はね やっぱり 2つに分けた方がいいんですね
まずあの訳があって怒ったと
仏教は怒ったことであなたは負けということははっきりしていますけど
我々俗世間では まあそこまでうまくいかないんだから
訳があって怒ったということと
訳がなく ただ単に込み上げてオラオラ出てくる怒りに 2つ分けた方がいいんです
理由があって怒った場合は
これはなんとか解決できます
理由がなく出てくる感情には解決法がないんだから
それはもうまず自分でカットしておくんですね
これはやめますと この怒りは
そういうふうに 2つに分ける必要はあると思います
怒りは怒りと異常 怒りとお釈迦様は 2つに分けてますからね
異常  全てですね なんか何かあると
そのおかしいんじゃないかというのがすぐすぐですね
すぐにはおかしいんじゃないかと出てきても
あ これで私が成長しなくちゃあかんないと
人間としてちょっと成長しようではないかということで
ちょっとプライドを持ってね
例えば電車にもカバン置いて二人分を取っていると
なんだこの野郎とまず思っちゃうね
わがままで自分だけ あ
この際 私が人間として成長する場だよと
あ これは何のこともなくいるんだと
もしか別な思考するのに
この人は座った時は誰にもいなかったんだから
隣のカバンを入れたと
まあそれは私でもやることだから
別に悪い行為ではありません
それでもしかすると 本人が誰か座ろうとするとカバンを取りますけど
まあ誰にも座ろうとしないんだから
本人はそのままいるだけのことでしょうと
だから誰も悪いわけじゃないんだから
じゃあそこら辺落ち着こうという方法は取れますね
もう一つは 頭の中で漫才作って笑っちゃいますよ
カバンだけじゃなくて
家にいる大型の犬も連れてきて
こちらに置いておいて
じゃあ今の女の電車でお化粧するんだから
お化粧で道具持っていって前の座席に置いてその方が楽しいんでしょとかね
そういうなんとか漫才作っちゃえば自分で笑っちゃいますから
まあ怒らなくなっちゃうんですね
けど 余裕を持って ちょっと大げさにやっぱり同じように考えない
そうそうそうそう 大げさに考えたら無駄になるんです
随分シンプルで考えるんです
馬鹿な場合は はい またありました
質問は  はい 最初の 4つにプラスって先生おっしゃったけど
技術とかその技術とか知識とか
直接金にする 財産にするとか
名誉のためじゃなくて
技術とか知識が欲しいとかっていうのは
それは 4つのカテゴリーにはみ出てしまわないんですか？ 最強の人はそう思わないでしょ
知識だけやればいいやとかね
それは財産があったりして
まあそれから余裕があったりすると
まあ知識だけに挑戦するぞって
例えばいろんなガラクタを集めているコレクターたちがいるでしょ
まだまだ財産があるんですよ
あの財産を無駄遣いしているだけに
だからコレクターはコレクター人生にコレクターに人生かけてるでしょ
何としてでもあれやこれこれ
それはなくちゃいけない
それはなくちゃいけないとかね
私の夢はこれだよって言っても
結局はそれはただ財産の無駄遣いだけであって
財産があるんだからそれやってるだけで
仏教から見れば全くもうダメな道なんですね
で 知識っていうのは やっぱりインドでは知識っていうのはやっぱり仕事のために
食べるために得たものなんです
知識人が知識で生きてるんです
じゃあ中国でも同じでしょ
あの皇帝のところで仕事をする何さんでしたっけ？あれは難しい試験があってね
夏 kyllin 神師ですか
...官僚になったらむっちゃ勉強するでしょ？すごい厳しい試験を受けたりして
でもう食べることも寝ることも全部やめてむっちゃ知識得る
しかし 合格したらもう楽々に生活できる
だからそれは財産を得る手段ですよ
それで この 仏教は知識も財産の一部にしているのです
だから傍がウパッジャントというところで
もうだからインドだったら家とか土地とか牛とかね
いろいろ財産あるでしょ
その中の一つは知識なんです
だから業にならないんです
それからもう現代社会ではたまたまそういう人々もいますよ
もう親がご飯くれるんだから
それを食べて 自分が何か別なことに凝ってオタクになって
そればっかりやっている
本人がいや 私はこれだけやって楽しいと言うかもしれません
それ人生の目的なんじゃないんですね
誰でも言えることじゃないんです
自分があえて変な道を歩んでいるんだということだけですね
一般論にはならない いるんですね
時々そういうね 何か変なことばっかずっとそればっかりやってるんで
仕事はしないわ もう何もしないとかね
それ人生の目的なのかと
そうじゃないんです だから一般的にまとめて豊かになりたいというのは
もう誰でもそれは手を挙げます
それは何か変なものに凝って
すべて人生を台無しにしている人に聞いても
あんた豊かになりたくないの？幸せになりたくないのかと言えば
それになりたいんですよ
はい またはい  今の少し似てるかもしれないんですけど
例えば芸術家の人が作品を作ってれば幸せなのか
音楽家の人が音楽やってれば幸せっていうのは
この 4つに入らない  あ
なるほど やっぱり売れなきゃ意味がないでしょ
芸術と音楽っていうのは
時々売れなくてそのまま死んじゃう人も
いるんですけど すごい不幸にするんですよ
だから目的に達することができなかったと
だから時に芸術 音楽っていうのは人が認めて芸術なんですよ
人が聞きたくないものは音楽じゃないんです
本人 自分が私が楽しい
勝手に楽しめと 来るなよと
森に森に人がいない 砂漠に入るとうるさいんだからってことになるんです
でも昔の画家なんかは
生きてる間は売れなくて
死んでから売れたり  絵の不幸でしょ
人生はみんな 本人は幸福に達してないんです
今のね 音楽とかね ベートーベンやらモーツァルトやらいろいろみんな派手に演奏したり聞いたりするんですけど
作った人には何の得もないんですね
はい めちゃくちゃ苦労して死んじゃっただけでね
そっちのその人々の話を聞いても
やっぱり音楽を認めてほしいと
仕事場が欲しいという気持ちはしっかりあったんです
絵を描いて誰も見るなよと暗闇に閉じこもる画家はいないんです
陶芸家が一所懸命作品を作って作って全部隠しておくと
ないんでしょ？やっぱり社会は認めなくちゃいけないんですね
認めて認めることが楽しいんだから
金がなくても認めてもらうことは楽しいってことなんです
そこで その人々は第一はあまり期待してない
2番目 認めることは期待しているんです
それが当然必要なんです
どうしてもこの世の中で価値っていうものは
自分と他人のコミュニケーションで成り立つのです
すべて金がそこで入ってくるんです
で 私は今長い時間喋ったんですけど
皆様方 みんなイスラム教だったらもう全然講演ではなくなっちゃうんですね
これもうとっくに殺されてるんで
で 皆様方は仏教に興味を持っていたんだから
そこで価値が現れたんです
一人が喋ってて 大勢の方々は聞いているんだと
もし私がお金でも取るならば
みんな何のことなく まあそれなりにお金まで払っちゃうと
そこでもう価値が成り立ってるんです
それ 人間との関係なんです
採算の場合 犬の面倒はいくら見てあげたっても何もくれません
犬は尾っぽ振ってくれますけど
それで関係は終わっちゃうんですね
だから世の中にはすべて芸術やら科学やら技術
何でもかんでも人との関係で価値が成り立つのです
新しいものを開発しても
誰も必要としないものは笑われちゃうんですよ
ある日本の発明家のおじいさんがなんか
あの 何て言いますか あの
雨が降って まあ服とかね
干すことできなくなっても
やっぱりずっと雨が降らないんだから
雨が上がったら干せるでしょうと言って
なんか傘 傘に何か道具をつけて
この何て言いますか 洗濯物を干せるんですね
傘さして洗濯物 あれ誰が使うんですか
パンツとか全部ぶら下がっちゃって出かけると
だからまあそういうのは価値がないでしょ
しかし ある発明がみんなに役に立つと
それすごい価値があるんですね
あの日本のナカマツさんでしたっけ
あの灯油をね 入れるあれ
ちょっとしたポンプを開発したでしょ
みんな使ってますからね
それは高価なものなんですね
そこで価値が成り立つんです
だからまあ そういう話がありますから
あの ただ芸術作品を作るだけで人生楽しいってことは本当は成り立たないんです
で 芸術は作って作って作っている人をちょっと見ても
すごい精神的にストレスかかったりして
すごい苦しんでるんです
その人は誰一人でもいいんだから
すごいですねと言ってくれると
そこで気持ちいいんですよ
そうでないと価値がないんです
本当は芸術作品っていうのはものすごい迷惑なんです
自然破壊だって迷惑なんです
しかし 人々は喜びますから
自然破壊でも迷惑でもなくなっちゃう
音楽も体に悪いし 耳に悪いし
うるさいし ものすごい不健康なものなんですけど
あんなに苦労して音を作るのかとかね
しかし 音を聴くと 聴く人々はなんとなく気分が良くなるんだから
そこですごい高い価値が生じるんですよ
はい そういうことで そういうことがあっても
お釈迦様の意思からははみ出せません
はい 質問がなかったら
はいはいはいはい こちら
こちら先はい 来ます はい
今日のお話とても良かったんですけど
ちょっと今のお話と関係してるので
一番姉が多分その自分一人で抱え込んで芸術にっていうタイプだと思うんですけど
そういう人をそこから出すっていうか
ということはできないでしょうか
本人が気づくように何か
まあ自分の芸術だからね
売れないものをいくらぶったってもガラクタでしようとかね
けなせちゃえばいいんじゃないですか
けなしたりとかしてるんですけど
なんかけなしたりあげたり両方やってるんですけど
そのまま こうだから閉じこもってる
じゃあ閉じこんだらね
苦しいんでしょ 苦しい
だからそれは別に心理的にアドバイスしてね
この閉じこもる性格を直してあげなくちゃいけないんで
芸術のことよりはね  というか
だから病気にもなってます
この心臓が悪かったり
それも全部抱え込んでるところから来てるように
私は勝手に思ってるんですけどね
そういうのはね あんまりにも自分のことって高く評価してるんですよ
すごい主観なんですね
主観は悪なんですね 客観的にならなくちゃ
慈しみで生きてなくちゃいけないんですよ
慈しみで生きて生きている人だったら
もう自分が絵を描いて
売れないんだったらそれでもいいんですけど
それはすごい綺麗やという人にあげますからねとかね
使ってくださいと 楽しいとよと
せっかく私が描いたものだからね
一人でもそれは評価するのはなんて楽しいでしょうかと人を喜ばせてあげるんですよ
そうするともうどんどん広げるんです
その慈しみがない人の芸術は芸術じゃないんです
自我を出すために描くものなんです
どんなプロテストの作品であっても
見た人が驚いてびっくりするのかっていう
客観的に見なくちゃいけないんです
自分の頭の妄想で何か考えつくっても
誰も買わないんです だからこの欠けてるのは
このすごい自我 エゴイストですというところと慈しみがないことなんですね
なんとかして慈しみを教えてあげることができれば
なんとかなるんだと思います
あなたにこれ欠けてるんだよと
慈しみだよと 売れるポイントは認められる
ポイントはね 慈しみがないとものすごく引きこもるんです
自分が引きこもるつもりがなくても
社会は無視されますから
もうとっくに引きこんでいるんです
慈しみが必要です 世の中で
前も言ったでしょ 価値っていうのは人との関係で成り立つんだからね
すごく物を大切にするし
慈しみの心も持ってるように私には見えるんです
それだとすごい明るいんですよ
それだったらすごい明るいんです
慈しみっていうのは 他人を引き寄せる力を持ってますからね
みんなそちらに強引に行ったりしてね
その人と仲良くしたりして
そのエネルギーなんですね
ものを大切にするっていうこと
これケチかもしれませんね
人に触るなよとかね 壊れるんだからとか
それはやってはいけないこと
触ってくださいと あと
そんなに触りたければとかね
壊れたらまあしょうがないでしょうっていうことでね
その人は明るいんです
あるいは自分のものだったら
触るなよ これは私の大事なものだと明るく言うんですね
そうすると この人のすごい好きなものだから
やっぱり放っておきましょうと
私の個人的なものなんで
私もいろんなものは人を触ってるの嫌でありますけど
それわかるとみんなわざとそれ触ったりとか
[笑い] 壊したりもする
ちっちゃな子供たちなんですけどね
やっぱり初めからもうものすごい注意するんで
遊んでもいいんだけど
遊んであげますけど これだけ触るなよとかね
それこの人はちらっと見てちょっとそこそこ回ったり
[笑い] なんかそれどういう感じ？別に物を惜しみとかケチとかないんです
だから結局でそういうものダメになっちゃいますけど
私はまあそういうケロッとそれはもう忘れちゃいます
まあ知ってるし まあ子供触ると壊れるでしょうと
触らないと 私は真剣だったら触らないところに置いておけばよかったんじゃないかとかね
だからまあしょうがないということにしますけどね
だからあのものを大事にするっていうこともちょっと微妙なんです
まあとにかく慈しみを教えてあげてください
なんとかなると言います
はい 後ろの方 はい  先生のお話の中で
後悔はいけないというふうによく
おっしゃることもあるんですけれども
教典の中にもそういうふうに出てると思うんですけど
それでは質問なんですけど
その後悔と懺悔の違いがちょっとよくわからないんですけど
その辺のところを  まあ懺悔っていうのは
まあ明るい行為ですからね
認めることでしょ 私は完璧じゃないんだから
ぐちゃぐちゃいろんなことやってますよと懺悔せばっていうぐらいのことで
それで立ち直るんですね
懺悔では立ち直るんです
後悔ではどんどんひどくなるんですね
後悔で後退するんです
まあダジャレで言おうと
[笑い] 懺悔では専心するんです
あの専心するために懺悔するんです
隠す 隠すことはしない
後悔でなんでやったのかとかね
という そういう風に怒りで持ってくることですよ
やっておけばよかったのにとかね
あれやらなかった方がよかったのにとかね
それは後悔です あ 悪いことしちゃったと認めて
あの専心することが懺悔なんです
わかりました  はい はい
すいません えーと あの心とですね
心と自我とは同じものですか？ まあ自我っていうのは心に起こる錯覚ですね
心のあるいろんな妄想がいるでしょ
妄想がいるの一つなんです
同じものじゃないんです
そうしますとですね あの
まあちょっと言葉の意味なんですけども
心と思考とか精神とか意識というものはどういうものなんでしょうか？どういう関係になるんでしょうか
生きてる機能全てまとめたら心なんです
呼吸することも 食べ物を消化して
代謝機能も血液の流れも全て生きてる機能でしょ
見ることを聞くこと 全て心なんです
だからたくさん複数の機能なんです
それで妄想するのも生きている証拠でしょ
それも心の一つの仕事なんです
しかし それ心とは言えません
ただ 見ることが心であると言ったら
見ることだけ心じゃないでしょうに
ちょっとした一つの仕事だけ聞くことも心ですけど
聞くことが心ですということではないんです
聞くことも一つの仕事
同じく妄想することも心の仕事
たくさん仕事の中で一つなんです
自我も妄想の中で生まれるすごいややこしい危険な幻覚なんです
あの自我っていうのは
まあ自我というのは 先生はよくお話やら本で書かれていらっしゃるように
要するに私というものがそのあるというふうに思い込むという状態が
その自我というものだと思うんですけれども
そうしますと その自我とか私という観念はいけないものだと思うんですけれども
そのそれを発生させる心というのは
いいものなんでしょうか
心いいものとは言わないんです
いい悪い問題じゃないんですよ
別に流れですからね で
例えば自我がどのように生まれるのかというのは説明できます
目で見て私が見たと言っちゃう
耳で聞いて私が聞いたと言ってしまう
それただの言語なんですけど
言語で主語なく語れませんだからね
見た 見た 見たと言っちゃう場合ははっきりと主語が入ってます
私がという だから言語上主語が必要だから
人間に主語が必ずもあるんだよというのはおかしい話なんです
見たことに私という 聞いたことに私という
味わったことに私という
考えたことに私という
でも見たものは無常でしょうし
聞いたことも無常でしょうし
考えたことは無常でしょうし
だから自我が成り立たないんですね
だから成り立たないものは幻覚の中で恐ろしいんですよ
あの自我の幻覚 恐ろしいのは自我があるんだから
能力はどんどん縮めていくし
もう固まるし 自分が心は発展しないし
成長はなくなっちゃうし
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみが出てくるし
だから悪の根源に数軸になっちゃうんですね
自我が それが幻覚ですね
しかし これは瞑想してちょっと成長しないともうなくならないんですね
あるいはすごい智慧がある人にとっては
よく因果法則を理解して理解して自我がなくないこともできますが
まあ人数は少ないと思います
あの とりあえず心はあってもいいわけですか？ あってもなくてもあるんで
昨日生きてる昨日だから
生きてる昨日があっていいか
なくて悪いかっていうそういう例じゃないんです
もう一応その機能は生きてる機能なんですよ
心とは生きてる機能 知る機能
あの 長くなっちゃうかもしれないですけども
要するにその まあ知識という知識という物質もうん
も 要するに心の心も無常だという
うん そうそうそう うん
その通りです 物質も無常で
心も無常なんです うん
それは発見じゃなくちゃいけない
心はもう断言 無常なんです
物質よりも無常のスピードが速いんです
僕はそう言われると質問なんですけども
あの 心の働きというのは
もう物質ある光の六根の働きで
心というのが生じるわけですね
そうすると その子供の話だと
子供の無常は光の速度の16倍だとおっしゃっていらっしゃいますけど
でもそうすると物質から物質である働きであるところが
その大変だった分 光の速度の16倍であるということは
ちょっと矛盾を感じるんですけど
うまく説明できなくてすみません
あの  まあとにかく心は無常であるということだけ覚えておいてください
ありがとうございます
はい どうぞ  好きな人がいて
ちょっとちょっと聞こえない
すごく好きな人がいて
その人がすごく忙しい人なので
なんか会うときにはなんかすごく楽しませてあげたいし
その人が癒されるようなことをしたいんですけど
でもすごく好きなので緊張しちゃってうまく話せない時とかがあって
すごく後悔しちゃったりするので
なんかどうすればもっとその人の癒しになってあげられるのか
なんかこう緊張しないように修行したりした方がいいのか
ちょっと待ってください
ちょっと経緯取らないと
この  私がそうですね 気づかせてない
好きな人 好きな人がいて
その人に癒してあげたいんですけども
好きな人だから緊張が先に出てどうにもならない
そのため修行したらいいでしょうか
あのね 好きな人に対してすごい緊張するっていうことは危険なんですよ
あのタレントさんみたいなもんだったらね
タレントさんとして ファンとして好きやというのはいいんですよ
見たところで本当に緊張してびっくりしちゃって
もうもう失神したっていうのは
それは普通ですよ でも
日常生活の中で好きっていうことは
一番緊張しないっていう意味でならなきゃいけないんですね
日常生活で好きな人がいるんだけど
緊張してビクビクするんだよっていうのは
あまりいい信号じゃないんですね
そこで本当にあなたにとってその人は合ってるかないかということは
その緊張がなくなった時わかるんです
それ緊張しすぎては全然うまくいかないんですね
で 人間同士で 我々大人だから言いますけど
まあ例えば私たちのような人間にもね
いろいろ仲良くしたりとかね
話したりとか いろいろあったりするのはいいんだけど
で 相手がちょっとしたことにも緊張してビクビクしてると
もう嫌で出て行けということになるんですよ
で 何のことなく すごい話したり
いろいろ冗談言ったり言い返したりすると
空気のようなことでうまくいくんですね
だから人に会って緊張するということは
すごい偉い人に会って
すごい有名な人に会って
自分が大ファンであったタレントの人に突然顔を合わせたりしてびっくりしたっていうのは
それは一時的なことだから
それは危険じゃないんです
しかし 好きな人っていうのは
我々毎日会って喋ったり
一緒に生活したりしたいんですよ
だから緊張をほぐすためには
まあただ自分には気に入ってるんですけど
そんなにどうということはないんだっていう気分になってください
私がびっくりしてるだけで
他の人は全然平気だよ
ただ普通の並みの人間でしょっていう気分にね
なってみてください で
だいたい人を好きになると
その人のいいところばっかり見えるんですね
自分に見えるんじゃなくて
頭で妄想するんですよ
だから実際にはないんですね
そこまでいいところは
自分の頭の中で作っちゃうんですよ
それで緊張しちゃうんですよ
それで それでも付き合ってみて
自分が思ったイメージとは違うことをわかってくると
すごいショックになったり
いろいろ問題が起こるんですね
だから安全対策っていうのは
好きのは好きだからしょうがないでしょ
だからいくらなんでも完全にいいったらないですよ
何か悪いところでもないのかどうか
それも探してほしいんですね
それで悪いところは知った上で付き合うという場合はとても自然なんです
後悔することにならないんです
知ってましたよと 初めから
そういう関係だったらうまくいくんですよ
お互いに問題なく ただ慰めてあげたいということは
女性の場合は良くないんです
かえってうざったいと思われるし
逃げはこの人危ない 精神的におかしい
逃げようということを思っちゃうんですね
女性っていうのはどちらかでちょっと微妙に支配する側に回らないと
人間関係がうまくいかないんです
あんたこうしなさいよとかね
いうふうな感じにならないと
あまりうまくいかないんです
そういうところを考えてください
あのー もうちょっと観察してみてください
あの 好きなセクションもあんたわかってるんだから
もう昔完璧じゃないんだからね
どう見たっても いろいろ変なところもあるんですから
それも見つけてください
それ見つかると 何のも緊張感消えると思います
はい それでは終了します
じゃあ回向の文  六方衆の三宝に帰依拝礼し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られます
サッビーティヨ ウィランジャントゥ サッバローゴ ウィナッサトゥ
マーテー バワットワンタラーヨ スッキーディーガー ヨコ バワ
バワトゥ サッバ マングラッカントゥ サッバ デーヴァタ サッバ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマヌバ
ーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥ テ
アビワダナシーリッセ ニッチャン ワッダ パジャーイノ チャッタロー ダンマ ワッダンティ アユワッノー スカンバナン
どうもありがとうございます